à toutes et à tous nous recevons à cet
instant monsieur
Louis pardon et de la Motte qui est le
secrétaire général de l'acnil
organisme qui nous est cher
et nous avons en fait Monsieur le
Secrétaire général du sujet abordés avec
vous
le premier c'est évidemment le rapport
annuel de l'acné sa présentation
traditionnelle devant la commission
puisque nous le faisons chaque année
mais ce n'est pas une habitude c'est un
intérêt dans ces conditions là ils ont
plaisir à vous écouter sur
le rapport et le bilan que vous allez
nous présenter sur l'activité de l'année
2022 et puis
un sujet législatif
puisque nos collègues marquis de Brest
et Arnaud belney en déposé un texte sur
la reconnaissance biométrique dans
l'espace public
qui fait qui était en réalité à
l'origine qui tient son origine plutôt
un rapport d'une mission de la
commission des lois auxquelles les deux
collègues avec Monsieur Jérôme Durand
que ces trois collègues ont rédigé et
dont est issus cette proposition de PPL
et sur dans leur rapporteur de ce texte
et le ministre Kester Philippe Bas la
commission des lois a désigné il y a
quelques semaines maintenant
j'essaye de m'adapter à chaque réunion
pour ne pas ennuyer les gens donc
je ferai tout pour que vous soyez
parfaitement à l'aise
et donc
nous plaisons mais c'est sincère ce que
nous avons
ils font des bêtises donc c'est
compliqué et à partir de là
votre point de vue en tous les cas votre
avis sur ce texte nous nous
faisait plus que nous intéresser
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
notre collègue est là bien évidemment
cet après-midi nous sommes là voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire sans être
plus long naturellement et vous laissez
immédiatement la parole et nous avons
peut-être le rapport d'activité en
premier ou le texte qu'on a rien convenu
de particulier les deux en même temps
oui je vais vous propose de présenter
les deux en même temps de moi merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président d'avoir
convié la CNIL à cette audition deux
points peut-être liminaire pour
commencer d'abord pour excuser
Marie-Laure Denis la présidente de la
CNIL qui présentait ce matin le rapport
d'activités à une conférence de presse
était cet après-midi au colloque
organisé par la CNIL sur les 45 ans de
la CNIL et demain à Bruxelles donc
malgré beaucoup d'échanges avec vos
services nous ne sommes pas réussis à
trouver puisque vous examinez le texte
la semaine prochaine une autre date de
décision elle m'a chargée vraiment de
vous redire à quel point elle en était
désolé et deuxième point luminaire pour
vous dire que nous aborderons avec
Madame Karine Kieffer directrice de la
protection des droits et des sanctions
vraiment brièvement le rapport annuel en
raison de la forte actualité de l'import
de cette PPL pour pouvoir concentrer ce
propos liminaire sur ce deuxième point
ensuite mais évidemment on répondra à
toutes vos questions pour préciser
éventuellement et je suis accompagné
aussi par Monsieur Bertrand pailletz qui
est le directeur des technologies et de
l'innovation et Christine berrichi qui
est la conseillère parlementaire de la
présidente pour commencer sans plus
attendre sur le rapport annuel donc
trois points très brièvement pour vous
présenter l'activité d'accompagnement de
la CNIL son activité de contrôle et de
sanction et peut-être mentionné quelques
dossiers saillants mais on pourrait
évidemment mentionner beaucoup d'autres
sur l'accompagnement c'est une activité
dont je tiens à souligner qu'elle est
toujours plus soutenue le rgpd en
supprimant le système des 100 000
déclarations autorisations par an et en
le remplaçant par un système où les
entreprises sont responsables et en
cours de Lourdes de lourdes sanctions si
elle ne respecte pas ses règles de
protection des données et bien créer un
appel légitime à de la sécurité
juridique pour tous ces organismes et
donc cette année encore la CNIL a
concentré ses efforts là-dessus il y a
une quinzaine d'actes de droits souples
guides recommandations référentielle etc
nouveau qui ont été adoptés et qui
s'ajoutent à l'activité plus
traditionnelle des avis sur les projets
de décret communication audition etc par
ailleurs il y a eu 1500 demandes de
conseils d'entreprises auxquelles il a
été répondu donc on nous dit comment
s'applique le rgpd à tel ou tel type de
situation c'est un chiffre qui se
maintient un niveau à peu près constant
chaque année on arrive à peu près à
toutes les traiter et nous avons
reconduit des méthodes d'accompagnement
innovantes sous forme de bac à sable bac
à sable non réglementaire et d'un
accompagnement individualisé pendant six
mois sur un projet en faisant des appels
à projets thématiques donc c'était la
deuxième fois qu'on le faisait ça a été
fait sur les aid tech les technologies
innovantes en matière d'éducation en
2022 et ça va être reconduit en 2023 et
comme ça beaucoup de succès ça va être
renforcé par un nouveau programme qu'on
vient de lancer d'accompagnement
renforcé qui lui sera non thématique
voilà donc le point principal c'est je
dirais un enrichissement de la palette
des méthodes d'accompagnement pour
pouvoir permettre d'avoir des
entreprises innovantes qui puisse lancer
les produits en ayant une assurance que
c'est conforme au rgpd je passe la
parole à Karine qui soit pour vous
présenter brièvement la partie contrôle
et sanction
merci Louis merci monsieur le Président
donc rapidement vous dire notre action
se divise en trois grands ensembles le
traitement des demandes des usagers les
contrôles des acteurs et les mesures
correctrices dans les mesures
correctrices on a tout un panel de
décisions mises en demeure appel aux
obligations légales sanction amende
injonction etc sur le premier volet de
la relation aux usagers nous avons
toujours un nombre conséquent plein
puisque nous en avons su plus de 12000
en 2022 un nombre aussi très important
de demande d'exercices des droits
indirects qui portent principalement sur
le FICOBA le fichier des comptes
bancaires qui sont intéressés à la CNIL
puisqu'on en a reçu plus de 7400 en 2022
soit une augmentation de de 27% et pour
la première fois depuis en train
d'application du rgpd nous avons réussi
à traiter plus de plaintes que nous en
avions reçu donc à clôturer plus de
plaintes que de plaintes reçues donc
c'était c'était une première depuis
18 nous avons essayé d'améliorer autant
que possible notre relation
usagers notamment par le biais de la
création d'un portail usagé pour que les
plaignants puissent avoir un compte en
ligne et nous nous solliciter échanger
avec eux nous avons aussi ouvert un
téléservice dédié aux demandes
d'exercice des droits indirects qui
fonctionnent depuis plusieurs plusieurs
mois
sur le volet des contrôles nous avons
contrôlé près de 300 fait effectuer près
350 contrôles cette année à nouveau
après la crise covid nous avons pu
refaire des coupes plus de contrôle sur
place puisque pendant la pandémie les
contrôles sur place étaient devenus
minoritaires mais nous avons pu revenir
à une situation normale de d'une
majorité de contrôle sur place et
notamment près de la moitié des
contrôles on pour origine des plaintes
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
nous tient beaucoup à cœur de faire nos
investigations sur de les préoccupations
des citoyens les préoccupations du
quotidien donc c'est c'est voilà un axe
que l'on se que le sens se fixe sur
notre politique de contrôle
s'agissant de l'activité plus répressive
la prise d'entreprise présidente de la
CNIL a adopté 147 mise en demeure en
2022 sur des problématiques divers et
variées mais on trouve une quand même
une presque une constante mais
énormément de manquement à la sécurité
des données qui qui sont présents dans à
peu près la moitié des mises en demeure
que la présidente a adopté
la Commission à la formation restreinte
et son président ont pris 21 décisions
de sanctions dont 13 sanctions publiques
une avancée très importante de l'année
2022 a été la création d'une procédure
simplifiée qui permet au président de la
formation restreinte de la CNIL ou un
membre qu'il désigne de pouvoir sur des
dossiers une présentation présentant pas
de complexité particulière prendre une
décision de sanction tout seul afin de
simplifier voilà ces procédures et puis
et de pouvoir aussi agir plus
efficacement dans le cas du traitement
des plaintes et prendre plus de
sanctions plus mineures parce que ces
sanctions sont plafonnées à 20000 euros
d'amende sur des cas de des cas de
mineurs et enfin pour pour en finir sur
l'activité quelques sanctions
emblématiques à savoir clear view sur
justement de un système de
reconnaissance faciale beaucoup de
sanctions dans sur le domaine des
cookies également contre Microsoft Apple
TikTok notamment et puis nous avons
aussi beaucoup participé à l'activité
européenne en examinant beaucoup de
projets de décision de nos homologues
dont une récente qui a fait grand bruit
hier la décision de l'autorité
irlandaise contre meta d'un milliards 2
euros voilà je m'arrête là
merci beaucoup et je souligne que la
CNIL a connu des taux de croissance du
nombre de plaintes qu'elle a reçu de 30%
plusieurs années de suite à la suite de
l'entrée en vigueur du rgpd et que donc
voilà le fait signaler qui consiste à
équilibrer avoir un taux de couverture
positif à traiter plus de plainte qui ne
rendent c'est un défi quotidien pour les
services pour Cannes qui font et pour
tous les services de ça direction on
était particulièrement heureux d'être
arrivé à passer ce choc très fort voilà
si vous le voulez pendant les questions
on abordera quelques si vous le
souhaitez dossier sur la protection de
l'enfance les caméras augmenter ou
l'intelligence artificielle mais je
passe donc pour ne plus attendre à
l'examen de la PPL biométrie dans dans
l'espace public en 2019 la CNIL a publié
une position un peu de principe
soulignant l'émergence de cette
technologie les dangers particuliers les
risques particuliers
quel présente
en contrepoids évidemment des
possibilités qu'elle offre et en
appelant un débat public au fait que
définir les usages que l'on accepterait
ou pas de la reconnaissance faciale
notamment dans l'espace public était un
choix politique important et qu'il
fallait donc un débat démocratique et
donc j'ai envie de nous y sommes avec
les rapports l'émission qui ont été
faites une PPN un débat
au Parlement des auditions alors pour
examiner cette PPL je vous propose de
procéder en deux temps d'abord rappeler
la doctrine un peu générale de l'acné
sur cette question sur la biométrie
ensuite les dispositions plus
spécifiques de la de la proposition de
loi alors quelques éléments de doctrine
générale
la donnée personnelle que constitue la
donnée biométrique est une donnée
particulière elle a toujours été
regardée comme étant d'une sensibilité
particulière pour la Cnil même si ça
n'est que le rgpd qui avec les progrès
technologiques
on a fait juridiquement ce qu'on appelle
une donnée sensible c'est-à-dire une
donnée dont le traitement est interdit
aux différents acteurs ou organismes
sauf avec le consentement de la personne
ou sauf quand une loi ou un texte
réglementaire selon les calias autorisés
pourquoi c'est sensible pas tant
généralement par son contenu parce
qu'elle dit de vous ça dépend en tout
cas des types de données mais parce
qu'elle va permettre votre
identification de manière unique et
quasi certaine selon les cas et qu'elle
ne peut jamais être changé elle ne peut
pas dans notre vocabulaire être révoqué
si elle est compromise elle ne peut pas
être modifiée
il faut s'intéresser aux différents
types d'usages de cette donnée parce que
selon ces usages et bien il y a plus ou
moins de risques j'essaierai donc de
cartographier brièvement les usages
d'une part les risques de l'autre alors
il y a des usages qui ne posent pas
tellement de difficultés qui sont des
usages je dirais de service et qui se
font avec le consentement des personnes
vous avez des usages sur les téléphones
portables qu'on connaît tous maintenant
pour les
identification l'authentification pardon
du téléphone et puis vous avez un
certain nombre de personnes qui viennent
nous voir qui viennent voir la clim en
disant je voudrais développer un service
avec de la biométrie avec le
consentement de la personne est-ce que
je peux le faire comment le faire etc et
le principal message de l'acné à ce
moment-là c'est de regarder
techniquement comment c'est sécurisé
est-ce qu'on demande le consentement de
la personne et est-ce que la donnée est
stockée en local à la main de la
personne sans base centralisée principal
préoccupation c'est qu'il est pas une
base centralisée avec toutes les
empreintes digitales les iris etc parce
que les attaque la question on dit
toujours c'est pas de savoir si on va
être attaqué c'est quand on va être
attaqué et il y a toujours du coup un
risque de compromission de cette base
toujours toujours il faut partir du
principe qu'à un moment elle peut
vraiment être compromise et donc
compromettre une base avec toutes ces
empreintes digitales c'est extrêmement
sensible problématique et donc on
demande à ce que le stockage soit
décentralisé une empreinte par téléphone
que sais-je à ce moment-là c'est
impossible d'attaquer pour récupérer
l'ensemble ensuite on a des usages plus
je dirais de police de
police avec différents degrés on peut
d'abord rechercher une photographie
un visage sur une photographie ou un
fichier de photographie c'est ce qui
existe déjà dans le Taj le traitement
des antécédents judiciaires on peut
prendre une photographie et savoir si la
personne elle est dans ce fichier un
degré de
d'intrusivité en plus vous allez
rechercher a postériori dans des vidéos
dans des ensembles de vidéos où il
faudrait les visionner pendant des
heures des heures des etc et vous allez
peut-être faire tourner ça pour
rechercher un visage de visage 50
visages mille visages etc c'est pas
autorisé à ce stade dans le droit
français c'est quand même le
prolongement de l'usage précédent on
passe de la de la photographie au film
et puis vous avez quelque chose ou
véritablement on change de nature qui
est l'usage en temps réel par une caméra
de vidéoprotection ou autre qui va
analyser et reconnaître en temps réel
des gens qui passent dans la rue dans un
magasin où que sais-je alors on regarde
ces différents usages et évidemment des
possibilités qu'offre la technique qui
sont indéniables il faut mettre des
risques les risques ils sont de 5 types
nous semble-t-il principaux d'abord il y
a un risque simplement sur la vie privée
le fait simplement qu'on va regarder
surveiller savoir que c'est vous qui
êtes sur cette photographie sur ce film
et évidemment notre droit protège la
possibilité de circuler notamment dans
l'espace public avec une forme de
discrétion une forme de
capacité à ne pas être filmé surveillé
reconnu en temps réel deuxième risque
ces systèmes font des erreurs ces
systèmes font des erreurs il suffit de
regarder
une série de faits divers pour voir que
dans des pays qui ont commencé à
l'expérimenter et bien il peut y avoir
des erreurs et donc on appréhende la
mauvaise personne elle est bloquée etc
elle est mise dans une procédure et tout
je dis pas que l'erreur peut pas être
acceptée mais ces systèmes font des
erreurs troisième point ces systèmes
peuvent avoir des biais discriminatoires
la manière dont ils ont été entraînés
fait que c'est ça s'ajoute à cette
notion d'erreur c'est une chose de faire
une erreur mais c'est une seconde chose
de faire plus d'erreurs sur les femmes
que les hommes ou les hommes que les
femmes plus d'erreurs sur tel ou tel
type de population que sur d'autres
quatrième risque la CNIL est
régulièrement confronté à des réflexions
sur l'inhibition de l'exercice des
droits qui
résulter de ce type de surveillance vous
avez le droit de manifester on va vous
dire pendant la méditation vous êtes
filmé et analysé avec de la
reconnaissance faciale pour des
finalités parfaitement légitime si vous
n'êtes pas
si vous ne pensez pas faire telle ou tel
type d'infraction il n'y a pas de
difficulté parce que du coup on entiera
aucune conséquence mais ça a un effet
d'inhibition sur l'exercice de certaines
libertés fondamentales que de savoir
qu'on le fera sous le regard d'une
caméra qui vous filme qui vous analyse
qui vous reconnaît et dernier risque un
risque de sécurité informatique parce
que comme je vous le dis s'il y a des
bases centralisées de données
biométrique elle s'expose à des
cyberattaques de plus en plus
sophistiqués de plus en plus forte la
sécurité
on ne peut pas assurer enfin dire à
l'avance qu'on assura de façon certaine
la sécurité de ces bases et donc elles
peuvent être compromises et ce sont des
données qui dans des mains malveillantes
ont une véritable valeur ils peuvent
être utilisés contre vous alors à partir
de cette doctrine il faut donc définir
des lignes rouges et des cas d'usage
c'est ce qui essaient de faire le débat
qui s'est enclenché et donc j'en viens
maintenant à la proposition de loi en
faisant un avertissement liminaire mais
très fort qui est de dire que le collège
de la CNIL ne s'est pas prononcé sur la
proposition de loi les commissaires du
collège de la clinique qui seule peuvent
prendre position officielle pour la Cnil
donc ce que je vais dire maintenant je
le fais avec une certaine prudence et en
insistant sur le fait que ça ne
représente que l'analyse des services
par rapport à ce qui est la doctrine
plus générale de la commission mais que
évidemment seul elle pourrait donner un
avis plus tranché que je ne vais le
faire bon principal message qui sache
pourra découle des délibérations de la
de la Commission du collège c'est que il
ne faut expérimenter ce type de
technologie notamment pour ce qui est du
temps réel dans l'espace public qu'avec
une main tremblante et une logique
extrêmement prudente et progressive de
notre point de vue le projet avec une
réflexion étayée certes mais propose de
procéder d'un seul coup à un
élargissement qui nous semble
considérable des cas d'usage et donc
nous allons dans ce message vous appelez
à les restreindre fortement alors je les
prends les uns après les autres il me
semble qu'on peut les regrouper en trois
cas l'authentification l'identification
a postériori et l'identification en
temps réel
l'authentification et le cas d'usage qui
pose le moins de difficultés
il faut le faire avec un stockage heure
locale non centralisée dans toute la
mesure du possible à la main des
personnes mais ce sont des usages que
nous connaissons déjà et dont je
souligne qu'ils sont déjà en partie pour
ce qui est prévu dans la PPL selon moi
permis par le droit positif
nous pouvons avec le réglement type de
la quinine faire de l'authentification
pour toutes les personnes qui sont
employées avec un sens assez large par
quelqu'un ça vaut nous semble-t-il aussi
pour l'organisation d'un événement et
donc il s'agit si je comprends bien
d'élargir d'ajuster d'affiner ce qui
existe déjà je souligne que ces systèmes
d'authentification biométrique sont
eux-mêmes faillibles toutes les
personnes qui sécurisent ce type
d'événements refusent généralement que
la sécurité se fasse uniquement avec de
la biométrie il faut ajouter du contrôle
humain d'autres dispositifs plus plus
classique regardez la nécessité au cas
par cas et le règlement type de la CNIL
qui existe déjà avec trois niveaux de de
dispositif possible et constitue un
point de référence
utile me semble-t-il
j'en viens au deuxième cas d'usage qui
lui est véritablement nouveau qui est
l'identification a posteriori avec deux
cas soit les enquêtes judiciaires soit
par les services de renseignement pour
des enquêtes sur des atteintes aux
intérêts fondamentaux de la de la nation
alors la relecture a posteriori de
documents comprendre dans une enquête
qui a été déclenchée et où je vais
chercher les visages des personnes et
d'une nature différente et moins
attentatoire que l'identification
en temps réel dans la rue des personnes
qui passent devant la caméra il y a eu
un événement je vais prendre des vidéos
et je vais regarder si je trouve
certaines personnes c'est quand même une
capacité de recherche dans la vidéo qui
est inédite aujourd'hui et donc il faut
absolument un certain nombre de
garanties et la première de ces
garanties c'est qui est véritablement un
contrôle humain une fois que sa Bible et
ça vous dit la personne est peut-être à
telle et tel endroit de la vidéo un
contrôle humain approfondie avant qu'on
prenne la moindre décision il faut se
poser et démontrer la question de la
nécessité et de la proportionnalité
est-ce qu'on a besoin de ce type de
réalité d'enquête aujourd'hui et si la
réponse est oui il faut en déterminer
les garanties à mettre en regard de ce
point de vue là sur les garanties nous
vous appelons à réfléchir sur trois
points le périmètre d'abord nous paraît
très large l'exposé des motifs parlent
des infractions les plus graves mais il
me semble que le texte permet de
l'utiliser pour tous les délits uniques
trois ans donc tous les vols par exemple
si je comprends bien tous les vols sans
aucune circonstance aggravante peuvent
faire l'objet de ce type de modalités
d'enquête pareil ne vous appelons à
insister sur ce qu'il y avait dans le
rapport sur le principe de subsidiarité
c'est à dire que cette technique de
fouille automatique de visage dans un
enregistrement vidéo et surtout si on
cherche beaucoup de visage je vais y
venir ça ne doit être que subsidiaire
par rapport aux techniques normales
habituelles d'enquête et surtout surtout
troisième point où nous sommes qu'il
faut véritablement creuser préciser
détailler encadrer restreinte c'est qui
qui est-ce qu'on va chercher sur la
vidéo est-ce que je vais chercher la
photographie d'une personne dont je veux
je sais que je la recherche à ton
warizon mais je sais que c'est elle que
je recherche et je prends
50 heures de caméra et je la recherche
c'est ce qu'il y a de moins intrusif
c'est comme si j'avais visionné les 50
heures pour chercher cette personne là
est-ce que je vais chercher un ensemble
de personnes dans un fichier de police
c'est déjà pas considérable de
rechercher tout un ensemble de personnes
dans le fichier des personnes
recherchées dans le Tage où il y a des
millions de de personnes etc ou est-ce
que je vais essayer d'identifier toutes
les personnes qui étaient là sur la
scène pour avoir leur nom uniquement
pour retrouver le nom des témoins ce qui
pour le coup est vraiment beaucoup plus
intrusif et ne pourrait être réservé
qu'à des cas nous semble-t-il d'une
extrême gravité donc là dessus il nous
semble qu'il faut beaucoup plus grader
et dire alors pour le renseignement il y
a déjà un encadrement mais qui peut être
préc on parle d'une personne
identifiée pour une menace on comprend
que c'est qu'une menace pour uniquement
les intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
que ce soit très clair on parle de
l'entourage est-ce qu'il faut pas aussi
préciser cette notion d'entourage et
pour les enquêtes judiciaires c'est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus large nous
semble-t-il trop large j'en viens au
troisième et dernier type de cas d'usage
les identifications en temps réel dans
l'espace public pour sécuriser les
grands événements pour les enquêtes
judiciaires les plus graves alors c'est
évidemment le point le plus délicat le
point le plus novateur dans la
proposition de loi et je répète encore
une fois que je ne parle que pour les
services de la CNIL seul le collège
pourrait prendre une position officielle
au regard des risques que je vous
décrivais tout à l'heure c'est
évidemment la teinte la plus forte à la
vie privée elle est vraiment d'une
nature d'une nature pour nous totalement
différente par rapport aux autres cas
d'usage la surveillance l'identification
se fait en temps réel au moment où se
passe devant la caméra c'est là aussi
que le contrôle humain va être le moins
efficace parce que je dois aller vite si
on fait du temps réel c'est parce qu'il
faut une réaction en urgence et les
faits divers dont je vous parlais c'est
toujours des réactions en temps réel
c'est différent de dans le cas d'une
enquête judiciaire ou je me pose je fais
saisir ou prendre communiquer tel ou tel
type de vidéo et je les regarde donc
pour les conséquences concrètes que
peuvent avoir les erreurs sur les
personnes ou des billets
discriminatoires sur les personnes c'est
là qu'ils seront de plus forts ça va
supposer de créer techniquement la
dérivation des images vers des
[Musique]
endroits où il y aura de la
reconnaissance faciale en temps réel
avec les données biométriques mises à
disposition et il n'y a pas évidemment
de système centralisé de vidéo
surveillance en France donc il va
falloir le faire dans tous les endroits
où on voudra le mettre le mettre en
place donc on va techniquement créer le
dispositif et mettre à disposition les
bases de données biométrique et elles
seront forcément centralisé et donc par
rapport au risque de sécurité que
j'avançais de compromission de ces
données c'est aussi là que le risque est
le plus fort et enfin c'est aussi ce qui
peut y avoir de plus inhibant pour les
personnes pour l'exercice de leur
liberté dans l'espace public j'insiste
sur le fait que la création même de ce
dispositif à titre expérimental serait
un pas fondamental
une voilà quelque chose de fondamental
pour la gestion de nos libertés
publiques alors que nous n'avons même
pas les idées claires sur l'efficacité
l'utilité de ce dispositif pour les
autres car d'usage actuellement et
j'insiste sur le fait que il n'y a pas
que la reconnaissance faciale dans
l'exploitation en temps réel des vidéos
il y a aussi la l'intelligence
artificielle sur les vidéos en temps
réel et là il y a une longue réflexion
qui s'est conduite depuis à peu près
deux ans sur ce qu'on appelle les
caméras augmentées ou les caméras
intelligentes et un parlementaire très
riche pour savoir dans quel cadre les
utiliser et le Parlement vient donc de
décider de tester cette technologie dans
un cadre dans la CNIL à lui-même à
elle-même soulignée je tiens à le dire
qu'il était précis encadré et permettait
une expérimentation de ce type de
technologie pour voir si elles
apportaient quelque chose à la
sécurisation des grands événements et
dans l'équilibre qui a été défini ainsi
que le Conseil constitutionnel vient de
le souligner il y avait l'idée qu'on le
ferait pas de reconnaissance faciale on
ne sait pas encore si les caméras
augmentaient aident véritablement à la
sécurisation des grands événements pour
donc sans reconnaissance faciale pour
reconnaître des faits de d'accrétion de
vol de d'attentat etc et donc il nous
semble que il faut enfin le collège a
vraiment pris parti pour que à ce stade
on en reste à regarder dans ce cadre
limité si ces caméras augmentaient sans
reconnaissance faciale euh sont utiles
et on ne met pas en place dans nos
centres de supervision pour les caméras
de vidéosurveillance de dispositifs de
reconnaissance faciale j'ajoute enfin
sur le contexte réglementaire que
au-delà de cette loi sur les jeux
olympiques qui vient d'être votée il y a
aussi un règlement sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui se pose expressément
cette question qui se pose la question
de savoir si on interdit comme ligne
rouge totale la reconnaissance faciale
dans l'espace public ou non et que là
encore le débat est en cours au niveau
au niveau européen et qu'il faut
peut-être le laisser se faire au niveau
européen dernier point sur cette sur ce
dernier usage quand on a une image à
exploiter dans le cadre d'une enquête
judiciaire et y compris une image qui
est repérée par une caméra augmentée qui
vient vous dire là j'ai repéré que pour
moi il y a une risque un risque
d'agression vous pouvez toujours prendre
cette image et l'interroger par exemple
dans le Tage pour savoir si cette
personne est présente dans le Tage donc
ce que veut dire c'est qu'une partie de
ce que la PPL veut autoriser de faire de
façon automatique et en temps réel et en
mettant des basses centralisées de
données biométriques dans les centres de
supervision etc ça peut aussi être fait
sans courir ses risques de façon
manuelle plus manuelle alors ça vous
allez me dire ça prend plus de temps de
récupérer l'image de faire
l'interrogation etc mais ce temps là
c'est le prix à payer d'une certaine
manière pour ne pas équiper pour
l'instant en tout cas nos
notre espace public de ce système ce qui
est encore une fois serait un changement
considérable dans la manière dont se
vive les libertés publiques en France
voilà donc en conclusion et encore une
fois un assistant sur le fait que c'est
une position des services de la CNIL il
vous appelle à restreindre le champ de
cette expérimentation pour effectivement
expérimenter progresser dans la
connaissance de l'utilité de ces de ces
technologies en expérimentant par
exemple le avec un encadrement renforcé
l'analyse a posteriori d'image dans un
cadre notamment judiciaire et en rester
sur ce point pour le temps réel à
l'équilibre qui vient d'être défini par
la loi sur les jeux olympiques
merci Monsieur précise de ces précisions
pardon alors on va dire la parole en
premier à notre apporteur monsieur
secrétaire général je vous remercie de
votre exposé très
très clair
et je voudrais directement aborder le
sujet qui fâche c'est à dire le dernier
que vous avez
abordé
nous sommes tout de même conduits à
essayer de rechercher
un bon équilibre entre les impératifs de
sécurité et la protection des libertés
fondamentales et du droit au respect de
la vie privée
et de manière presque intuitive je
dirais que tout de même alors que de
grands événements se préparent
il pourrait être
a postériori cette fois regrettable si
il menace réalisée de ne pas avoir mis
en oeuvre tous les moyens de la prévenir
je comprend très bien les arguments que
vous utilisez je voudrais être certain
d'avoir bien compris
là où plusieurs d'entre d'abord est-ce
que vous craignez que l'installation
de caméra
dédiée à l'exploitation de leur donner
par l'intelligence artificielle dans des
lieux déterminés et temporairement
ne soit maintenu en place après la fin
de l'expérimentation si celle-ci n'était
pas reconduite j'ai cru comprendre que
vous aviez cette crainte d'une
pérennisation qui s'imposerait
d'elle-même si la loi décide que ce ne
sont pas les caméras de vidéos
protection mais un dispositif
particulier et temporaire il me semble
que elle sera respectée je voudrais
mieux comprendre parce que vous avez
abordé ce sujet
la position dont j'ai bien compris que
c'était celle des services de l'acnil
sur ce point et puis il est vrai que le
texte de la proposition de loi il s'agit
de son article 5 semble mêler des
procédures qui relèvent principalement
de la police administrative avec
d'autres qui s'apparentent davantage à
celle qu'on utilise dans les enquêtes de
police judiciaire
est-ce que on ne pourrait pas imaginer
de clarifier
tout ceci en respectant la cohérence
d'une action qui est une action en
réalité de renseignements c'est-à-dire
de police administrative et en essayant
d'apporter à cette action
les garanties maximales dont nous
puissions disposer et peut-être
d'ailleurs celle-ci
se trouve-t-elle dans le système
d'autorisation de l'usage des techniques
de renseignement elle-même par la loi de
de 2015 sur le sur le renseignement si
on avait affaire à une demande
d'autorisation par la direction générale
de la sécurité intérieure dans des lieux
clairement déterminés à l'occasion de
grandes événements qui comporteraient
comme caractéristique non seulement
entre guillemets leur grandeur mais
aussi le fait qu'on a des raisons de
penser que des menaces graves
d'attentats terroristes ou criminels
sur le déroulement de ces événements que
on est identifié très précisément les
personnes
à surveiller et celle-là seulement et
que l'autorisation donnée à ce moment-là
par le Premier ministre après avis de la
Commission nationale du contrôle des
techniques de
renseignements puissent éventuellement
être déféré au Conseil d'État en cas de
doute soit de membres de la cnctr soit
de personnes qui
se sentiraient concernés par cette
décision est-ce que
dans la mise en oeuvre d'une technologie
dont vous redoutez le principe même de
tels modalités serait de nature à
atténuer vos craintes
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
j'ai juste une question
subsidiaire mais qui a beaucoup
d'importance pour l'acnil
dans le rapport des députés Philippe
Gosselin et Philippe platonbe il y a une
recommandation qui nous paraît
intéressante je voudrais savoir ce que
vous en pensez c'est celle d'élargir la
composition du collège de la clinique au
président de larsep et de l'arc comme
pour
en matière de système d'intelligence
artificielle renforcée l'expertise du
collège
Jérôme du Rhin a demandé la parole
merci monsieur le Président c'est le
secrétaire général merci pour votre
propos liminaire et l'analyse que vous
avez faite du travail parlementaire qui
qui s'ouvre ici
j'étais un des rédacteurs avec mes deux
collègues
et de belles Ned du rapport
j'ai choisi avec mon groupe de ne pas
m'associer à cette démarche un peu pour
les raisons que vous avez évoquées dans
une prévention globale sur une démarche
qui embrasse un peu large au champ
législatif on était sur un rapport on
est sur une proposition de loi on n'est
plus exactement dans le même exercice
j'ai entendu vos propos et la prudence à
laquelle vous nous appelez j'ai quelques
questions à vous poser
est-ce que s'agissant d'un débat dont
vous avez souligné
le saut technologique auquel il appelle
est-ce que vous avez des comparaisons
avec des pays étrangers chez des
instances de régulation ou des autorités
comme la vôtre qui permettrait de nous
éclairer sur la façon dont le débat de
ses conduit dans ces pays deuxième
question
le Conseil constitutionnel s'est
prononcé sur le texte Jo et sur les VSA
soulignant en particulier
le non recours aux données biométrique
est-ce que vous y trouvez une matière à
analyse qui pourrait nous être utile
pour le texte qu'on va
discuter ensemble bientôt troisième
question qui était annexe mais qui porte
peut-être plus sur votre activité
courante
en lien avec les caméras toujours j'ai
entendu parler d'un site qui permettrait
aux citoyens d'exercer leurs droits
d'accès aux images de via un formulaire
pour la préfecture de police si j'ai
bien suivi leur facture de police a
décidé de filtrer les demandes en
autorisant que des demandes papier
est-ce que cette limitation
ne restreint pas l'accès aux images pour
les citoyens voilà les quelques points
que je que je voulais vous interroger
merci
merci y a-t-il d'autres questions ça n'a
pas d'autre de la parole merci monsieur
le Président
sur
les questions relatifs à l'usage en
temps réel deux points d'abord pour
préciser
mon propos effectivement
je ne crains pas du tout
pour les services de la CNIL le
réfrigérateur pas du tout le fait que
parce qu'on fait une expérimentation ce
sera forcément pérennisé ça j'ai
vraiment aucun doute que si c'est une
expérimentation la loi dit c'est
pourtant d’année
l'état droit en France fait que ça
s'arrête à la fin des années ça repasse
chez vous tant que vous le Parlement
tant que le Parlement ne dit pas il faut
continuer on continuera pas et tout ce
qui aura pu être monté si on continue
pas sera démonté ça vraiment
c'était pas du tout ça que je voulais
dire et pardon si c'est pu être ça a pu
être ambigu ce que je voulais dire c'est
que il y a une différence forte sur ce
type de système nous semble-t-il entre
l'instant où inexiste pas et donc où ils
ne peuvent pas être utilisés et donc ils
ne peuvent pas non plus être détournés
et l'instant où ils existent et où
effectivement
on met des garanties juridiques qu'on
prévoit un encadrement mais leur simple
existence est déjà une forme de choix de
risque donc pour lequel comme le disait
la tenue en 2019 bah c'est un choix
politique
très fort et de ce point de vue là
effectivement c'est moins risqué si on
utilise des caméras adoc qu'on
installerait pendant quelques heures à
un endroit sur un système
Haddock qui serait démanté ensuite et
branché un coffre-fort très très sûr où
il y aurait la base de données
biométriques et qui serait ensuite
détruit je parle pas moi le spécialiste
je vais parler dans un instant de passer
la parole à Bertrand mais généralement
me semble-t-il opérationnellement et en
tout cas ici ce qui a montré tout le
débat sur les caméras augmentées c'est
pas ainsi qu'on peut procéder et donc en
tout cas pour les caméras augmenter la
sécurisation des grands événements on va
je dans certains cas on va pas monter
quelques caméras Haddock mais on va
dériver les images du système de
vidéoprotection qui existe sur un
système elles ont une centralisé
généralement des distances de de
supervision et où on va utiliser
brancher une analyse logicielle
automatique qui va
faire fonctionner le système donc il me
semble que pour que la PPL soit
expérimenté sur le temps réel et pour
que sur la base de telle ou tel
événement on déclenche
[Musique]
à la demande de l'autorité judiciaire
pendant 48 heures renouvelables etc un
système ou sur tout le territoire ou
partie du territoire si vous restreigner
le dispositif on va rechercher une de 50
000 ou des millions d'images par rapport
à l'objectif qu'on se fixe il faudra
qu'il y ait ce système me semble-t-il
dans les centres donc voilà c'était ça
mon point c'était que choisir de
l'expérimenter c'est déjà choisi de le
et c'est ça dont nous trouvons que c'est
un c'est un saut qu'il faudrait pas
franchir après si le débat démocratique
le Parlement éclairé par toutes les
personnes qui leur a entendu et voilà
lance cette expérimentation à l'évidence
il faut prévoir un système de garantie à
la hauteur des risques que je décrivais
et donc pour en tout cas l'usage des
techniques de renseignement le système
qui a été mis en place et
et robuste il faudrait certainement pas
y déroger il faudrait un minimal le le
transposer d'ailleurs c'est l'esprit de
la de la PPL peut-être sur l'aspect
installation je laisse Bertrand Paillet
développer un peu
oui non vous avez vous avez presque
presque tout dit effectivement ce qu'on
constate dans ce qu'on a compris du
déploiement des caméras augmentaient
donc de le projet de logios c'est
effectivement alors soit un système
installé un peu large échelle sur Paris
notamment qui permet la Préfecture de
Police de centraliser les images et
d'appliquer les algorithmes dessus mais
c'est vrai que c'est deux aspects
différents c'est-à-dire la récupération
des images et l'application d'algorithme
de détection d'événements dans le cadre
de la loi JO c'est évidemment d'autres
algorithmes de reconnaissance faciales
qui peuvent être mises en place mais
toujours sur les mêmes images et puis
dans d'autres cas d'usage qui nous
avaient été cités comme par exemple des
marchés de Noël évidemment on peut être
des endroits où il y a pas forcément de
caméra installer donc dans ce cas là on
a installé les caméras on va installer
les fournisseurs de solutions d'analyse
qui sont d'ailleurs souvent ça peut être
couplé aux caméras mais c'est souvent
quand même des des gens différents les
gens qui fournissent les caméras les
gens qui fournissent les systèmes
d'analyse d'analyse automatique et puis
le
dernière source d'image qui est spécifie
à cet événements c'est évidemment les
images qui viennent des drones qui sont
elles généralement déployées au moment
de l'événement uniquement et qui
fournissent des sources de données
particulières qui peuvent soulever au
passage des défis notamment pour les
détections d'événements parce que ils
sont mouvants ce qui peut rendre
difficile en fait l'analyse des images
je reviens peut-être à la question du
coup sur la composition mais on peut y
revenir du collège de la CNIL alors là
encore pardon de répéter ça évidemment à
chaque fois mais je peux pas vous donner
le la position du collège donc je
commence par dire que je vais quand même
répondre à la question mais que ce que
je dis peut-être que le collège me
démentirais entièrement il me semble que
objectivement la les
interagulation est de plus en plus
nécessaire les sujets sont de plus en
plus imbriqués le numérique est de plus
en plus régulé il y a qu'à regarder le
nombre de textes européens qui sont
adoptés au cours d'adoption sur le
numérique et de loin qui porte sur ce
domaine et donc il faut absolument et
c'est ce qu'on fait que la CNIL parle
sans cesse à la recom larcome à la CNIL
la CNIL à lacep donc de ce point de vue
là le besoin il est réel par ailleurs il
y a déjà une une expérience
d'hybridation de ce type qui est que le
président de la CADA ou sont
représentants siège au collège le
président en espèce de la présidente de
la CNIL où sont représentants sièges au
collège de la CADA c'est remarquable de
mon point de vue ça permet une fluidité
là où l'articulation de ces deux lois
avec une qui protège les données
personnelles y compris dans les
documents administratifs et l'autre qui
dit c'est document administratifs de
pouvoir être communiqué aux citoyens la
plus large mesure possible et quand même
quelque chose qui a mis du temps à se
stabiliser ce dialogue permanent avec
ses membres qui assistent au collège
l'un de l'autre de mon point de vue
modeste et un système qui fonctionne
tout à fait après un point d'attention
sur la proposition que vous évoquez qui
est que le collège de la CNIL est déjà
un collège très large de 18 commissaires
beaucoup plus large me semble-t-il que
les collèges des autres
zaïques qui sont plus sur des modèles de
6-7-9
membres tous les membres sont
indispensables et admirables mais voilà
18 + 2 ça fait 20 c'est encore plus
j'en viens à la question sur la
comparaison avec les autres pays alors
je suis un peu sec je vais essayer de
répondre ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a
des avis enfin il y a des discussions
avec les autres CNIL le Comité européen
de la protection des données le contrôle
européen
l'équivalent de la kiné pour les
institutions européennes le dps qui ont
pris des positions extrêmement fermes
sur le troisième type de cas d'usage la
reconnaissance faciale en temps réel
dans l'espace public donc le
discours très réservé sur le dernier
type de cas d'usage que je vous tiens il
est tout à fait en cohérence avec celui
de je pense la totalité des CNIL et de
la vie officiellement rendu par le
Comité européen avec le contrôleur
européen dans le cadre du règlement sur
l'IA la proposition de règlement sur lia
de la Commission après moi je ne sais
pas dire exactement ce que les autres
pays font en pratique je sais pas si
Bertrand ou Karine ont des éléments je
crois qu'il y a relativement peu de
choses parce que pour les caméras
augmentaient on n'était pas les premiers
à voter une loi de ce type les Camara
augmenter donc sans reconnaissance
faciale mais quand même on était dans
les premiers dans mon souvenir de
l'étude de droit comparé
je sais juste que aux États-Unis des
systèmes de reconnaissance faciale sont
utilisés également à des fins
commerciales puisque je crois que dans
l'état de New York il y a une obligation
d'information quand c'est utilisé par
des magasins par exemple donc mais je ne
sais pas pour répondre à la question de
comment le débat c'est nouer je sais pas
du tout comment on le dépasse aux
États-Unis
et en Angleterre peut-être
se souvenir d'un
fait divers mais alors je sais pas où
quelqu'un avait été pris pour du pont de
Ligonnès en Angleterre par un système de
reconnaissance faciale donc il devait
bien y en avoir un et s'est retrouvé
plusieurs jours
donc peut-être en Angleterre aussi
sur la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur la loi
sur les JO
oui tout à fait alors je ne dis pas que
parce que le Conseil constitutionnel est
toujours très prudent dans ces
rédactions donc il va dire la loi qu'on
me présente elle a fait si elle a fait
si elle a fait ça elle a dit qu'il y
avait pas de reconnaissance faciale et
telle qu'elle est je la trouve
équilibrée donc ça voilà on ne peut pas
faire dire au Conseil constitutionnel ce
qui n'a pas dit qui est cueilli
refuserait considérer un constitutionnel
toutes choses là-dessus mais tout de
même c'est il choisit de relever un
certain nombre d'éléments dont il estime
qu'ils sont nécessaires à assurer en
l'espèce la proportionnalité de la loi
et ça fait évidemment partie on aurait
été surpris évidemment de l'inverse des
éléments qu'il a qu'il a relevé mais
au-delà de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel en toute fin de course
j'insiste sur le fait que ce débat a eu
lieu dans le cadre de la sur la
sécurisation des des grands dans le
cadre de cette discussion de loi il y a
eu des amendements des c’était bien et
normal enfin que la question soit posée
puisqu'il s'agit de sécuriser des
événements qui vont présenter des
risques extrêmement extrêmement lourds
et que
pas seulement la CNIL mais aussi le
gouvernement ce sont prononcés contre
cette expérimentation de la
reconnaissance faciale en vue des Jeux
Olympiques en estimant me semble-t-il
indépendamment de tout ce dont je vous
parlais sur le principe même d'installer
ces dispositifs en mettant aussi en
avant le fait que il fallait il reste
relativement peu de temps pour
expérimenter les choses que nous
n'utilisons pas du tout aujourd'hui pour
la sécurité des grands événements etc et
que déjà dans un cadre restreint et sur
lequel la relative consensus s'était
formé testé expérimenté trouver déployer
acheter des systèmes de caméra augmentée
efficaces qui apporte véritablement une
contribution à la sécurité à la
sécurisation des JO étaient déjà
un défi donc ça nous semble au-delà de
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
vraiment appelé du coup à la à la
restriction au fait de ne pas prendre ce
dernier cas d'usage enfin corrigez moi
du coup si j'ai je déforme la question
vous parliez d'un système de droit
d'accès aux images de vidéoprotection
notamment celle de la préfecture de
police de Paris où ne serait accepté que
les demandes papier alors je donne une
réaction là aussi à chaud et avec
beaucoup de prudence et tout en première
réaction il me semble que ça ne
rencontrerait pas les enfin ça poserait
une difficulté au regard du du rgpd et
du peut-être aussi du code des relations
entre le public et l'administration le
rgpd demande que on facilite les
l'exercice des droits d'accès
rectification etc
ces images alors non je dis des bêtises
parce que le système en question il
relève surtout enfin il relève en partie
du rgpd pour ce qui est finalités non
pas de police mais pour la plupart de
ces finalités relèvent de la directive
police justice mais qui prévoit la même
facilité enfin d'exercices du droit
d'accès la CNIL a une jurisprudence
entre guillemets qui proportionne la
facilité de demander aux responsables de
traitement à sa taille ses moyens etc et
donc à partir d'une certaine taille on
demande que ce soit acceptée des
téléservices des saisines par voie
électroniques et pour des autorités
publiques autorité publique en première
action j'aurais tendance à dire qu'on
l'exigerait d'autant plus que le code
des relations entre le public et
l'administration prévoit de façon assez
générale c'est à dire à 100% là sans
vérifier si ça rentre à local mais que
on doit pouvoir saisir l'administration
par voie électronique alors l'acné l'a
toujours un peu les deux faces
c'est-à-dire que quand il y a que de
l'électronique
n'arrête pas de répéter de dire il faut
aussi qu'on puisse saisir par papier
parce que il y a des gens pour qui il y
a des difficultés d'équipements ou des
difficultés de maniement et à l'inverse
quand on dit il y a que du papier
parfois parfois on dit
u égard à vos moyens vous devez mettre
en place une télé procédure pour
permettre un accès un exercice facile de
ses droits voilà en HO comment mais sans
certitude je réagirais
merci Monsieur Lamarque mademoiselle oui
Président c'est juste pour ajouter un
élément complémentaire je crois que
c'était avec Gérone Durand nous avons
auditionné nous avons été dans
l'entreprise Thales et vous parliez tout
à l'heure de comparaison avec des
équipements étrangers ils nous ont dit
avoir équipé à l'aéroport de Singapour
et d'autres endroits aux États-Unis
alors si vous voulez avoir des éléments
complémentaires je crois qu'il vous
suffit d'aller en banlieue parisienne
pour déjà demander ce qui s'est passé et
ce qu'on fait nos entreprises françaises
à l'étranger sur ce sujet là
je crois que c'est une question
y a-t-il d'autres
qui est très juste c'est un fait que
l'Europe c'est de tes de textes très
différents et qui repose sur des valeurs
très différentes d'autres
parties du monde
c'est évident alors la CNIL
j'avais la présidente de la CNIL elle
est en ce moment
elle n'a pas pu venir parce qu'elle est
un colloque sur les 45 ans de la CNIL et
alors dans son discours inaugural elle a
cité à un ancien président de la CNIL
Monsieur Jacques Fauvet et alors j'ai
pris la page du discours là en sortant
parce que je me suis dit que c'est on
était exactement là-dedans et Jacques
Fauvet écrivait donc en 1988 le
législateur et la commission qu'il a
créé n'ont jamais voulu empêcher ni même
gêner les progrès des sciences et les
techniques comme parfois le reproche a
pu leur être fait en 1988 leur est-il
prétendu que les enseignements de
l'histoire les auraient confondus loin
d'entraver les développements de
l'informatique la CNIL les a rendus plus
crédible et plus efficace dans la mesure
même où elle a toujours veillé à ce
qu'elle soit au service de chaque
citoyen et donc vraiment je tiens à
marteler que la position de la CNIL
n'est pas du tout une position anti
technologique et d'ailleurs sur les
caméras augmentées elle a discuté avec
le gouvernement de façon extrêmement
fructueuse fait des propositions
gouvernement pour définir un cadre pour
utiliser ces caméras augmenter pour la
sécurisation des Jeux Olympiques le
gouvernement a repris toutes ses
propositions le Parlement a améliorer le
projet le Conseil constitutionnel la
valider et on n'a pas manqué d'être
critiqué par une partie de la société
civile consistant à dire que déjà ce pas
là allait beaucoup trop loin était
inacceptable etc donc l'idée n'est pas
de d'empêcher la technologie mais il
faut aussi enfin la mission confiée par
le rgpd par ces textes à aux
administrations françaises et notamment
à la CNIL et bien de prendre
particulièrement en compte le fait que
installer dans l'espace public dans dans
les centres de supervision des systèmes
qui permettent de comparer avec des
données biométriques les personnes en
temps réel est un changement de nature
dans la manière dont on vivra l'espace
public alors même que on vient de voter
une loi qui propose de sécuriser les
grands événements en expérimentant des
caméras simplement augmenter ce qui est
déjà un pas important et dont il n'est
pas sûr aujourd'hui quels seront utiles
ou pas à nos services de police c'est
comme ça a été dit si le bilan montre
qu'elles ne sont pas utiles comme tout
ça n'est pas fait pour faire des gadgets
et retarder l'action des services de
police mais uniquement les aider il ne
faudra pas pérenniser et renoncer à cet
outil
vous l'ajoutez quelque chose juste pour
signaler qu'on est bien on a été
sollicité par plusieurs industriels
français tout à l'est sur l'initiation
de la reconnaissance sociale dans un cas
d'usage qui n'est pas celui de la
proposition de loi qui est plutôt le cas
usage de l'embarquement dans des avions
notamment des aéroports qui
effectivement en place à Singapour dans
plusieurs aéroports américains donc
c'est pas une finalité de sécurité sur
une finalité de confort pour les
voyageurs
qui soulève d'autres questions notamment
parce que notre homologue italien enfin
il y a une expérimentation également en
Italie sur le sujet donc sur une base
juridique le projet note donc
sur lesquels on discute avec nos
homologues et également avec les
industriels ce qui français qui sont
particulièrement bien placés cette
technologie
et de façon plus générale la CNIL a
validé un certain nombre d'utilisations
de la reconnaissance faciale notamment
l'expérimentation en aéroport chez j'ai
compris que Thalès c'était plutôt équipé
pour des pour des finalités de police
pas pas pour des pour le fonctionnement
des aéroports
mais ouais c'est ça
bien pas d'autres questions vous êtes
suffisamment éclairé enfin nous sommes
suffisamment éclairés
écoutez merci beaucoup monsieur
merci merci à vous